♪ ♪
>> Sean: AS WE TOLD YOU EARLY
IN THE SHOW, DEMOCRATIC
INFIGHTING AND CIVIL WARS
INTENSIFYING TONIGHT AS THE FAR
LEFT RADICAL PROGRESSIVE PARTY
IS DOUBLING DOWN, THEY ARE
SAYING NO INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL
WITHOUT THE MASSIVE 3.5 TRILLION
RECONCILIATION PACKAGE TO GO
ALONG WITH IT.
THEY TRY AGAIN TO SNEAK AMNESTY
IN IT.
SENATOR MANCHIN, WEST VIRGINIA,
FIRED BACK IN A STATEMENT,
CALLING THE TRILLIONS IN
SPENDING "FISCAL INSANITY."
LET'S SEE IF HE HOLDS THE LINE.
HERE TO REACT TO ALL OF THIS,
HE'S THE AUTHOR, TEN SOLID WEEKS
IN A ROW, NUMBER ONE ON
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" LIST,
AMERICAN MARXISM, OVER A MILLION
COPIES, A MILLION AND A HALF IN
PRINT.
HE HOSTS LIFE, LIBERTY AND
LEAVEN HERE IN THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
NATIONALLY SYNDICATED RADIO
HOST.
YOUR PRODUCTION IS GETTING TOO
LONG.
I JUST CALL HIM THE GREAT ONE.
GOD BLESS US, HOW AM I?
>> WITH BOTH GOING OVER THIS
WITH A FINE-TOOTH COMB.
THEY EVEN HAVE A MILEAGE TAX IN
THIS THING.
200 -- YOUR BOOK IS CALLED
AMERICAN MARXISM.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU WARNED
ABOUT.
AND YOU HAVE CHAPTER SEVEN, YOUR
LAST CHAPTER, OVER 10,000 WORDS,
IT GIVES US THE ANSWER.
HOW DO YOU STOP THIS?
>> FESTIVAL, I WANT PEOPLE TO
KNOW, THIS IS WHAT 2500 PAGES
LOOKS LIKE.
THAT IS IN ONE BILL.
THAT I WOULD ASK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT'S
IN THIS BILL?
MOST OF YOU DON'T, BECAUSE THE
PRESS ISN'T REALLY TELLING YOU
OTHER THAN A FEW PLATITUDES.
SEAN, WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO HIT
ON ARE THE LIES THAT WE'RE
GETTING ABOUT THE DEBT, ABOUT
THE DEFAULT, BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS AND EVERY ONE OF THESE
DEBATES TRIES TO SCARE THE HELL
OUT OF THE AMERICANS, WE ARE
GOING TO DEFAULT ON OUR DEBTS
SAYS THE TREASURY SECRETARY,
SAYS THE HACKSAW ON BIDEN, SAYS
NANCY PELOSI, WE ARE NOT GOING
TO DEFAULT ON OUR DEBT.
LET ME GO THROUGH THIS VERY
QUICKLY.
AND BY THE WAY, I HAD A COLLAR
TO MY RADIO SHOW THAT SAID HEY
LOOK, IF THE $5.5 TRILLION IS
ALL PAID FOR AT NO COST, WHY ARE
WE RAISING THE DEBT CEILING
ANYWAY?
SO IN OTHER WORDS, IF THE LIE IS
THAT THIS ISN'T GOING TO COST US
ANYTHING, IF IT'S ALL PAID FOR,
WHY IS THERE EVEN A DEBATE ABOUT
RAISING THE DEBT CEILING?
THE GOVERNMENT WON'T DEFAULT ON
THAT SERVICE, BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
OAKS, LISTEN TO ME CAREFULLY.
THE TAX REVENUE CONTINUES.
WE GET ABOUT $320 BILLION IN A
MONTH, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOES, ALL FORMS OF TAXATION AND
FEDERAL USER FEES AND GET THE
DEBT SERVICE IS A LITTLE OVER
$44 BILLION A MONTH.
320, 44.
THERE'S WAY MORE THAN ENOUGH TO
PAY FOR THE DEBT SERVICE.
YOU'VE BEEN HEARING DEMOCRATS,
YOU'VE BEEN HEARING FOOLS ON TV
SAY THINGS LIKE THIS IS TO PAY
FOR TRUMP'S SPENDING.
NO IT'S NOT.
RAISING THE DEBT CEILING IS FOR
FUTURE SPENDING ON FUTURE
PROGRAMS.
IT'S NOT FOR PAST PROGRAMS.
IT RAISING THE DEBT CEILING IS
ABOUT FUTURE SPENDING.
NOW ALSO, THEY TALK ABOUT
SOCIAL SECURITY.
THE WAY IT WORKS IS IF WE DO NOT
HAVE AN INCREASE IN THE DEBT
CEILING AND YOU HAVE
$320 BILLION COMING IN.
AT THE FIRST AMOUNT OF MONEY IS
TO PAY THE DEBT SERVICE,
44 TRILLION.
44 BILLION A MONTH.
THEN SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE ARE PAID.
FEDERAL PENSIONS ARE PAID.
AND THEN BEYOND A FEW MORE, THEN
THE POLITICIANS HAVE TO WORK OUT
THE REST OF WHICH IS PAID.
OH, ISN'T THAT TOO BAD?
THEY ARE ONLY GETTING
$4 TRILLION A YEAR, BUT THEY
WANT A LOT MORE.
SO I'M JUST MAKING THE POINT
THAT THE DEBT, THAT THE CREDIT
ON THE DEBT, THE FULL FAITH AND
CREDIT OF THE UNITED STATES
CANNOT BE VIOLATED UNLESS THE
TREASURY SECRETARY AND THE
PRESIDENT DO IT PURPOSELY, WHICH
IS A VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW
AND THE FEDERAL CONSTITUTION,
BUT HERE'S WHAT I THINK THE
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO DO.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO PUT IN
PLACE THE MOST MASSIVE SOCIAL
ENGINEERING AND WELFARE STATE IN
WORLD HISTORY.
THEY WANT TO TURN YOUR LIVES
INSIDE OUT AND UPSIDE DOWN.
THEY WANT TO DRAW ALL
CONCENTRATION OF POWER FROM YOU,
YOUR FAMILY, YOUR FAITH, YOUR
COUNTY, YOUR TOWN, YOUR STATE,
INTO WASHINGTON, D.C.
SO WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO?
I THINK THEY WILL AGREE TO LOWER
THE AMOUNT, BUT THEY WILL STILL
HAVE ALL THIS STUFF IN THIS 2500
PAGE BILL.
IF SO THAT THEY CAN ENSHRINE AND
PUT IN PLACE THESE THINGS.
THEY DON'T REALLY CARE ABOUT THE
DEBT, SO PEOPLE LIKE MANCHIN AND
PERHAPS SINEMA CAN SAY WE
LOWERED THE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
IF I HOPE THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
ONE OTHER THING.
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA SAYING BIDEN
SHOULD ACT UNDER HIS OWN UNDER
THE 14TH AMEND IT.
WE HAVE SOME A CONSTITUTIONAL
IGNORAMUS IS ON TV, IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE.
THE 14TH AMENDMENT SAYS
AUTHORIZED BY LAW, INCLUDING
DEBTS INCURRED FOR PAYMENTS --
SUPPRESSING INSURRECTION SHALL
NOT BE QUESTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU HAVE TO PAY
THE DEBT SERVICE.
THIS DOESN'T GIVE THE POWER TO
THE PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
TO TAKE OVER THE POWER OF THE
PURSE.
ARTICLE ONE, SECTION 8,
CLAUSE -- THIS IS A SMART
AUDIENCE, THIS ISN'T MSNBC, THIS
ISN'T CNN, THIS ISN'T THE
NETWORKS.
THIS IS FOX.
IT'S OF THE CONGRESS SHALL HAVE
POWER TO LAY AND CONNECT TAXES
TO PAY THE DEBTS AND PROVIDE FOR
THE COMMON DEFENSE AND GENERAL
WELFARE OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S A CORE DUTY OF CONGRESS.
THE NEXT SECTION SAYS THAT
CONGRESS SHALL HAVE POWER TO
BORROW MONEY FROM THE CREDIT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE GUYS LIKE
CLYBURN AND OTHER SAYING
JOE BIDEN SHOULD JUST SAY I
CAN'T LET THE UNITED STATES
DEFAULT ON ITS DEBT AND EXERCISE
THE 14TH A MOMENT, UNDERSTAND
THESE PEOPLE ARE INCREDIBLY
STUPID.
BECAUSE AGAIN, THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO DEFAULT ON THE DEBT.
SOCIAL SECURITY WILL BE PAID,
MEDICARE WILL BE PAID, THE
PENSIONS WILL BE PAID, AND WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS REALLY WANT IS AN
OPEN CHECKBOOK TO SPEND WHATEVER
THEY WANT, AND TO THE
REPUBLICANS' CREDIT, THEY'VE
SAID NO.
NOW, HERE'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON.
McCAULEY POINTS OUT THERE'S
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN THIS BILL WITH HIS LEFT-WING
COMMUNITY ACTIVIST GROUPS.
THIS BILL NEEDS TO BE KILLED.
I DON'T CARE WHAT THE COST IS,
IT NEEDS TO BE KILLED.
>> Sean: YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
SAY THAT SAID, I'M DONE.
THANK ME.
>> I FORGOT.
>> Sean: YES.
[LAUGHTER]
ALL RIGHT, DON'T FORGET TO WATCH
MARK'S SHOW SUNDAY N